hello everyone and welcome to game one
of round one of the meltwater champions
chester it's the start of the
uh magnus carlson invitational
preliminaries and uh it's a very nice
game between jordan van forest and the
magnus carlson
of course it's uh again the rapid time
format and
we're gonna discuss a little bit more
about the tournament but as usual
uh whenever a tournament starts i just
show the first game and then we discuss
the tournament as the tournament uh
slowly progresses uh but it's the part
of the magnus carlson invitational so
you pretty much know what's
what's happening here so now let's check
out the game and then we're gonna see uh
what's what so uh when forest with the
white pieces opens with
e4 and we all know what magnus replies
the e for that of course is the sicilian
defense with c5
knight to f3 and the g6 going for this
hyper-accelerated dragon variation
uh we have bishop to c4 not going for
the open civilian with
d4 and now magnus goes bishop to
g7 uh we have c3 and now d6
uh we have d4 striking in the center and
we have a trade captures captures and
now
knight to f6 putting pressure on that e4
pawn and
uh one force defends it with knight to
c3 and
castles by magnus uh now this bishop
here could come under attack uh after
moves like queen to c7
uh so you don't you you very rarely
wanted to stay on c4
pretty much in all lines against the
ceiling you will play bishop to b4
and now magnus continues development we
have knight to c6
and now h3 preventing this normal
development of the bishop
with b5 now by magnus and this is the
the star move of the show it's not a new
move it has been played before but only
three times in in
um in international events
uh and the idea is that uh of course
you're offering this pawn and it seems
like you just want to trade or for the b
pawn for the e4 pawn but it's actually
much much stronger than that what
what you've done here is you've opened
up the bishop to play bishop to a6 and
grab hold of this diagonal and this
would be
kind of problematic for white because
black would very gladly give up this
pawn deliver check now you have to bring
the knight back otherwise you're going
to lose the knight so knight c3 and now
bishop to a6
cuts off the king from castling and this
is what magnus was going for
yeah but one for us of course not
interested in that he just
castles and now comes b4
so moving uh away this knight from the
defense of the e4 pawn so now
knight to d5 and now what do you do here
it seems like um
when forest is offering the e4 pawn but
can magnus
really grab it uh if you go knight
captures an e4
then you get queen to c2 with this uh
double attack
this knight is under attack and this
knight is under attack and you will lose
one of the knights so
it's actually not a free pawn uh so
instead after knight to d5 we have
knight captures by magnus bishop
captures
and now uh bishop to b7 defending the
knight on c6 and
preparing rook to c8 and here there is
one game in the database where rook the
e1 was played but here
uh we have instead of rook d1 bishop to
e3
and it is now as of move 13 that we have
a completely new game
so let's see how magnus deals with it he
first starts with rook the c8 and it
does make sense the c file is the only
open file on the board
and now queen to a4 uh putting pressure
on the c6 knight here and also
uh on the pawn on a7 so if you remove
the defender of the pawn you can
eliminate the a7 pawn
uh we have e6 magnus even tries to force
this and while you could do this for
example uh bishop captures bishop
capture so now you could
grab one of the pawns uh it could be a
bit uh risky
uh getting the queen uh you know uh so
so deep into the opponent's position but
also white black can just grab the e4
pawn as well so it's not
not all that impressive so instead after
e6 evan forest just goes back bishop to
b3
and now knight to a5 now you can see
that this
queen isn't doing all that great uh okay
the b pawn is still uh uh you know uh
possible
it's possible to capture the b4 pawn uh
but you could very easily see something
like queen to b6 bishop to c6 and
the the white queen is trapped but it's
not so easy
so first uh the the e4 pawn is under
attack and
we start with knight to d2 on force now
the defense d
for pawn and now we have d5 by magnus
uh we have rook f the c1 uh offering a
trade of rooks and now
knight captures on b3 if you start with
queen to b6 it seems like a bishop to c6
should be winning for for black but
there is this rook to c5 controlling
the square and also attacking uh the a5
knight and now you don't really have
anything better than knight captures on
b3
so magnus skips all this and he goes
knight captures on b3 right away we have
eight captures on b3
and now a trade on c1 we have rook
captures with check
rook captures and denial d captures on
e4 we have queen captures on a7 grabbing
back the pawn
and bishop to d5 now cementing this
bishop here
and as you can see the material is
completely even uh magnus has a double e
pawn one four says the double b pawn but
magnus has the bishop pair so if
that bishop pair can come alive uh black
should have a slight advantage so here
rook to c7 uh definitely
advantageous for white to grab hold of
the seventh rank like this now black
will have
troubles developing here because you can
never develop the rook you start losing
everything along the seventh rank so
here queen to a8
magnus has to kick away the queen the
queen simply cannot remain there
we have knight to c4 the knight is now
excellently placed here because
it's either a very strong piece or you
have to capture it and then
uh white fixes his pawn structure so
magnus trades on a7 with captures
captures and
now f5 defending that e4 pawn and maybe
preparing f4 in some lines
uh so here while when forest could
defend with the g3 he actually allows
magnus to push
f4 so he goes knight to e5 and now
f4 attacking that bishop bishop back to
d2
and now magnus eliminates the the knight
on e5
uh because even though he has the bishop
paired the knight on e5 is just a
monster
so here he starts with bishop captures
on e5 d
captures on e5 and now g5 and now
that's a very very impressive pawn chain
here and magnus will now
start bringing his king into the game
hopefully you want to trade off
the the pair of rooks but in this
position uh
if you traded off the rooks uh you would
be left with
opposite colored bishops and that means
that you will not be able to push for
more than a win here
uh more than a draw here and i forgot to
mention uh i think
i'm not i'm not sure because i only
caught a glimpse of the live coverage
now i think when forest was
late to the game and then that he lost
some seven minutes six or maybe seven
minutes on the clock maybe even eight
and that he started with with a with a
deficit on the clock i could be wrong on
this but i i think it is so
so here after g5 we have bishop captures
on b4
now attacking the rook here and rook the
c8 magnus is now ready to bring the rook
to the second rank
uh we have bishop to c3 preventing this
and now
bishop captures on b3 so magnus is ready
to create a pass pawn here
whereas one forest has a pass pawn but
it's currently being blocked by the
bishop so here
rook to a3 chasing the bishop back
bishop to c4
and now bishop to a5 this is a very
important move as it covers the b6 and b
for squares
and now of course you will start pushing
your past pawn
so bishop to d5 and now rook to c3 when
forrest wants to trade off
the rook so he he wants to enter the
opposite colored bishop end game and he
does have the outside pawn
uh not completely outside but outsider
than all the other pawns and here if you
traded rooks uh
it's pretty much a guaranteed draw so
rook the b8 magnus still wants to fight
here
and now b4 the pawn is very well
protected on b4
and king to f7 now magnus starts
bringing the king into the game maybe
you can even sneak the king over to f5
maybe grab the pawn
uh we'll see how it goes so rook to c7
check
king to g6 and now rook to d7 preparing
rook to d8 to again try and trade off
the
the pearl rook so here e3 magnus creates
a pass pawn with
f captures f captures and now uh rook to
d8
as planned magnus again of course
declines this will rook to b7
and now uh rook to f8 and this is where
van forest could have gone
a little bit better with a move like g4
completely cutting off
magnus from entering the game with his
king uh it would be
it would be somewhat harder for for
magnus to make progress here however
after this rook the f8 move
uh he gives magnus a a a very nice
idea magnus plays bishop to c4 now he
cuts off the king from entering the game
the pawn and bishop controls these
control these two squares uh we rook the
f6
check came to g7 and now rook to f3
uh attacking the pawn and forcing the
pawn to come to e2 so the king can come
to f2
and here we have pawn to e2 and now
we have this very tricky position where
van forest needs to prevent the pawn
from queening
and of course there's a perfectly
natural way to do this just king to f2
and everything is fine or or is it uh
the point is uh what you have to play
here is actually b5 the
king f2 just doesn't work you have to
give up some material to save the game
and then after for example rook captures
you're going to play bishop to e2
you're going to give up another pawn and
then you're going to play king f2 and
try to fight this however when forest
played king to f2 right away
thinking that okay i mean it's the exact
same thing but it's actually not so feel
free to pause the video here
and win the game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
thinking outside of the box and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
bishop to b5 you already know what
white's plan is white's plan is to push
b5 so why not prevent
white from pushing b5 so it's not the
exact same thing king f2 followed by b5
or b5 followed by king to f2 because
then
you could have played b5 now magnus no
longer allows it bishop to b5
this is the only winning idea so
congratulations to everyone who found it
and now it's very very hard for
for white to play this we have rooked
the e3 but now rook to f7 check we have
rook to f3
magnus again declines the trade rook to
d7 he wants to get behind the white king
we rook to e3 again trying to eliminate
this pawn even at the price of
rook because that's your only way to
save the game but magnus of course
doesn't allow it rook to d2
uh we have bishop to b6 now trying to
activate the bishop somehow and
rook to b2 uh we have bishop to d4
attacking the rook now just
rook to b1 uh preparing this uh rook to
come to f1 and now you really don't have
uh
anything anything good here you you
could try sacrificing here
uh but now after king captures you also
lose the b4 pawn so you really do
have no compensation here uh with the
pass b pawn it's maybe possible to
prolong and maybe hope that
black blunder something but here not so
much so here after rook to b1
bishop to c3 but now rook to f1 with
check we have king to g3 and now h5
completely cutting off the white king
from the game all of these squares are
now covered
uh we have h4 and magnus goes g4 not
allowing the king back into the game
we have rooked the e for now uh but it
doesn't help just
rook the c1 attacking the bishop here
and now the bishop can no longer help
out here
we bishop to d2 attacking the rook we
have brooke the d1
and it was in this position animal 50
that jordan one forest resigned the game
and uh the first game of the tournament
uh in round one goes to magnus carlsen
uh so very nice game very nicely played
i particularly enjoyed that b5 move sort
of like uh
like a reversed evans gambit uh sort of
thing because i know how much you guys
enjoy the evans gambit and all
uh so hope you hope you like that idea
as well uh but yeah here you resign
because your bishop is under attack and
there's nothing you can do
if you move it you don't really have a
good square to move it if you go bishop
to c3 then rook d3
check and then the bishop is lost so
that's
one way to do it and the other way to do
it is to simply move the bishop
somewhere
that does not cover the e1 square for
example you could go bishop to f4
but then we just bring the queen into
the game and the white has to part with
the rook and that's just it
black again has the winning advantage so
after rook to d1 when force resigned and
an excellent victory for magnus carlsen
in round
one we'll see how it goes and will he be
able to continue this but
these are only the preliminaries however
you still have to play well in order to
get in order to qualify for the main
event which we are going to discuss
at length uh starting with game two uh
game three game four and all of the
other games that we're gonna cover
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
sean o'connor uh the good stuff raji
david kimura alan callahan and bruce
moody for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all uh i will see you
soon
and have an excellent rest of
of of your day sorry i forgot something
so i had to do it now
uh see you soon guys